Speaker 1: You know, when we talk about
Republicans claiming to have principles. And then
completely ignoring those principles. It often
is when it comes to things like economics, Oh,
the debt and deficit. We really only care about
that when the president's a Democrat. All right.
I gotcha. Or, you know, business regulation. We
don't want to regulate business. And until it
becomes inconvenient, then we want to regulate
business. But even with these so-called culture
war, social issues, these are the absolute biggest
hypocrites. It turns out that anti drag everything
she's against drag shows, drag queens, drag
kings, everything. Marjorie Taylor GREENE
has a boyfriend. He's the guy from
Right Side Broadcasting Network. I know.
And it turns out he is dressed in drag. And,
of course, she's defending him. So here's the
video that has now been unearthed. Here is
Brian Glenn in drag saying he kind of likes
wearing his pantyhose. Take a look at this.
Speaker 2: I could tell you I don't think I
think a lot of people are up now. They're all
hashtag. I am. Of course. Come and check it
out here. So I saw him Saturday. I am kicking his
shoes off. But I may keep the pantyhose on. That's
still kind of good. Lot him, I promise you.
Speaker 1: That he might keep his panty hose
on. So that's Brian Glenn in drag. So, of course,
Marjorie Taylor GREENE would denounce this, right,
Because she's against this. She says this is
grooming and this is dangerous and it's obscene.
And I know she defends it. Marjorie Taylor GREENE
taking to Twitter where she posted, quote, I'm
literally lolling. Brian Glenn dressed in drag for
morning news in Dallas years ago, reporting on an
upcoming local theater production. And the morons
over at Patriot takes think this is an attack.
Brian loves the throwback and is reposting,
laughing, crying emoji. The left is so stupid. Oh,
okay. Okay. We know that they are hypocrites on
the big issues that deficit, business regulation,
etc. but it seems like they are truly hypocrites
about everything. Even the social issues, even
the culture war issues, all of it. Does it matter
why you dress in drag now? Before it was. Oh no,
no. When men dress in drag, it's predatory and
it's bad and it's grooming and it's dangerous
and all of these different things. Now it's. Well,
no, hold on. If you're dressing in drag to promote
a theater production, then it's okay if you dress
in drag to, I guess, read stories to kids. That's
what's bad. It's not the drag. It's the fact that
they're doing it around children or whatever the
case may be. These people are completely
and totally vapid. There is nothing there.
And they are hypocrites on every single
one of these issues. Marjorie Taylor
GREENE at the absolute top of the list.
I know people keep writing to me saying,
David, you should really cover this relationship
with Brian Glenn because Marjorie Taylor GREENE
claims to be a Christian and sanctity of marriage
and all these different things. It seems almost
like it's certain that she was with this Brian
Glenn guy having an affair even when she was
still married before she was separated or getting
two guys. I don't care. Yeah, Like, obviously,
I'm sure she's a hypocrite. Lauren Boebert is now
getting divorced, even though she said Christian
people aren't supposed to get divorced, they stay
together. You work through all these different
thing. They're hypocrites. They're all hypocrites.
I really don't care about her personal life other
than the hypocrisy. But even like the affair,
all these people who preach the Bible are having
affairs. Many of them, not all of them. I want to
be careful. It's not new. But she is the same type
of pathetic hypocrite that we've been following
for a long time. So there it is. Antidrug drag,
Marjorie Taylor GREENE, boyfriend in
drag in this particular case. It's fine.